そうか
今日は湿気が強いのか
まあ
パサパサだし何なの水泳のせいもある夏家の生命大阪させてやばいね
フォスタークラウン host are you doing は今チャンネル登録車
200に行きました
ありがとうございます8本当にいつもこんな僕の勝負な不敵 granite がを見
てくださっている皆さんのおかげでございます皆さんの内角を暇つぶしになればいいな
と思ってるんでもしよかったらこれからの暇つぶしに
また適度に見てくださいまたよろしくお願いします
で本題に移るんだけども気分を一新しようかと思いますで僕は今年が学生最後の夏なん
で最後はねでバーってきてるんですよぱっと出たらちょっとでまずまずはイメージを
変えようと思って髪の毛をちょっと
めっちゃくちゃのルクシオ乗ってあげますよそりゃもうなくどこにでも一応めちゃ
付き合いの明るさみーだろうと思っていこう
美容室にってか染めたんだ
けれどもそれで完成したのがこちらになります
th
ホストじゃねーかーしゃないよチャラすぎるじゃないよこれは何でこうなったらどこで
店確かめだけさっき今雑誌を見るんですよ子
どんな色がいいですかねそれ以降パンってさせて上から白っぽいキーン立つ白っぽい
近々ロッテコーナーがヤンキーみたいなイメージがあるんですけどそのヤンキーの金色
からちょっと黄色を取ったような珍しいなぁ寝台の色
をやってたんですなぁと今も+なぁ者じゃねぇ禁断はこの日金結構シルバーというかな
ちょっと白っぽいならちょっとギンポ行きんだったんですけどもその次の日はマーキン
キンになっちゃったわけなんですよカツラじゃないから本当の金だからみんな勘違いし
ないんだけどヤンキーとかじゃないけどねちゃん描写が200万いったということで
数字は気にしないんだけども何か変
彼がしたいと思ってね木花になって今3日目なんですけども頻発になって変わったこと
をそっとみんなに紹介してあげようと思います
がああぁぁぁぁぁぁ
んですよねぇー素性やでー
さてっちゃちゃー
ああああああ
まあまあ人髪でしたよ
マナー
金髪にしたよん
me
ずっと待って帰ってこないんだけど
あ貴族推察受けたくていたふーんおった
ん
の
ていた
藤五郎腰でしか見えないよプレ月んねしたということなので皆さんも早く見慣れて
くれるとありがたいです
一発はねやっぱり人生に一度やってみたかったんやってみたんですけども悪いことも
たくさんあるよって言葉が飯田ドン月
てゆけな金髪になったということとチャンネル登録者700万人を超えましたあなたは
いいんですけどみんなの暇つぶしになればいいなと思ってるんでありルーク
よろしくお願い致しますじゃじゃーん
ana
ban
i am
ん
me
あの結構気に入ってます
スーパーサイエンスみたいさっき